bine ai revenit la Quantum Computing în practică, eu sunt Olivia Lan și episodul de astăzi, numărul trei, se va concentra pe un
experiment qaoa la scară de utilitate dacă ai fost cu noi de la început, ai văzut cum am parcurs
hardware-ul IBM Quantum, cadrul de tipare Qiskit și cele mai recente tehnici de atenuare a erorilor care
sunt folosite de cercetători și dezvoltatori pentru a scala circuit-urile Quantum ne-am simțit că era cu adevărat important să îți oferim tot acest
context și să îți arătăm direcția în care ne îndreptam, dar acum nu mai există niciun motiv să așteptăm mai mult pentru a vedea toate aceste informații în
acțiune acum câteva lucruri de reținut înainte de a începe totul va urma cadrul de tipare Qiskit
deci vom parcurge acești pași în ordine: numărul unu este maparea problemei, doi optimizarea circuit-ului, trei
executarea cu Primitives și patru postprocesarea sau analizarea rezultatelor vom începe cu un exemplu destul de mic
ca să poți înțelege cel mai bine acești pași și scopul lor, apoi vom discuta un exemplu foarte asemănător, dar mult
mai mare pentru a-ți arăta cum ai putea scala problema până la nivelul de 100 de qubit-uri o să îți ofer toate
instrumentele care să îți permită să mergi mai departe după această lecție și să rulezi acea problemă independent în sfârșit, aceasta nu va fi
o prezentare a codului, indiferent cât de mult am încerca pe măsură ce progresăm, codul îmbătrânește și devine depreciat, deci dacă ajungi
să vizionezi acest video la un an după lansare, nu vreau să te blochezi pe sintaxa care s-ar putea schimba ușor în timp, în schimb, aceasta va fi o
discuție detaliată despre logică și enunțul problemei cu toate acestea, există un tutorial sub formă de notebook care însoțește acest
video și este atașat în descrierea de mai jos urmând codul sau consultându-l după ce
vizionezi această lecție și rulându-l tu însuți îți va oferi cea mai bună experiență de învățare posibilă deci, ca un scurt memento, nu
toate problemele computaționale sunt potrivite pentru Quantum Computing problemele ușoare și calculele simple nu trebuie să profite
de această tehnologie deoarece calculatoarele clasice sunt deja perfect capabile să le rezolve începând cu 2024,
cele trei domenii în care suntem cel mai optimiști să explorăm sunt acestea: simularea naturii, procesarea datelor cu structură
complexă și în ultimul rând optimizarea problemele de optimizare sunt unele dintre cele mai dificile probleme computaționale
de rezolvat eficient într-o problemă de optimizare cauți cea mai mare sau cea mai mică valoare posibilă
pentru o funcție de cost dată cu toate acestea, pentru multe probleme de interes, găsirea acestui extrem devine exponențial mai
dificilă odată cu dimensiunea problemei de aceea devine atât de greu de calculat ca exemplu, poți imagina cât de
dificil poate fi să calculezi traseele optime de zbor sau rutele de livrare în toată țara în această lecție vom
explora o problemă particulară de optimizare numită Max cut care o vom rezolva folosind un algoritm
Quantum numit algoritmul de optimizare prin aproximare cuantică sau qaoa deci ce este problema max cut? o
problemă de tăietură maximă este un tip de problemă de optimizare combinatorică definită pe un graf, unde scopul este să
partiționezi vârfurile grafului în două submulțimi astfel încât numărul de muchii dintre cele două submulțimi să fie
maximizat deci, de exemplu, în acest graf, fiecare nod este conectat astfel și max cut-ul este arătat de această linie ondulată
care împarte nodurile în grupul violet și grupul gri modul de a face aceasta trecând prin cel mai mare
număr posibil de muchii este să tai prin cinci muchii pentru acest graf deoarece graful este atât de mic
nu este dificil să încerci câteva tăieturi posibile pe hârtie sau chiar în mintea ta și să îți dai seama că cinci este cea mai bună opțiune posibilă
dar imaginează-ți că numărul de noduri s-ar dubla și apoi s-ar tripla rapid, devine imposibil să faci asta
manual și după un anumit număr devine atât de complicat încât chiar și supercalculatoarele se chinuie să returneze cel mai bun răspuns, aceasta deoarece
numărul maxim de tăieturi crește exponențial cu numărul de noduri deși acest lucru poate părea puțin abstract,
există multe probleme din lumea reală care pot fi formulate ca o problemă Max cut, cum ar fi detectarea fraudelor în finanțe,
clustering pe grafuri, proiectarea rețelelor și proiectarea VLSI, de asemenea analiza rețelelor sociale
cea din rețelele sociale este deosebit de ușor de înțeles să zicem că vrei să găsești un grup de persoane care au cele mai multe conexiuni posibile
cu alte persoane de pe o platformă de socializare pentru a identifica utilizatori puternici sau persoane care au
cea mai mare influență într-un grup companiile chiar încearcă să facă asta destul de frecvent un ultim punct aici: max cut este adesea
o subrutină a unei probleme mai mari, deci s-ar putea să nu definească aplicația propriu-zisă, ci să fie folosit pe fundal este
mult mai comun decât ai putea crede la prima vedere acum este timpul să începem
primul pas este să creăm graful nostru poți face asta importând un pachet Python numit rustworks definește câte
noduri ai specificând numărul n, apoi adaugă nodurile la graful G va trebui de asemenea
să trasezi muchiile vom face asta manual aici listându-le într-un array ca acesta, unde arăți ultimul
număr care specifică ponderea muchiei sau cât de puternic sunt conectate cele două noduri specificate, aici vom
păstra o pondere de unu pentru toate, dar s-ar putea să îți placă să te joci cu ponderea mai târziu și să vezi cum se schimbă soluția
pentru a înțelege ce înseamnă ponderea în acest context, să revenim la exemplul nostru cu rețelele sociale poți gândi
această pondere ca nivelul de influență pe care o persoană îl poate exercita asupra alteia conexiunea ta cu soțul/soția sau cu o rudă
ar primi probabil o pondere mai mare decât cineva care este doar o cunoștință acum trasează-ți graful
tutorialul atașat îți va arăta sintaxa corectă mai întâi înainte de a considera cum să
mapezi această problemă pe un circuit Quantum hai să construim puțin context despre cum devine problema max cut o problemă de optimizare
în primul rând începem prin a considera minimizarea unei funcții f de x, unde intrarea X este un
vector de dimensiune n ale cărui componente corespund fiecărui nod al grafului vom face referire la această funcție de acum
ca la funcția noastră de cost, apoi trebuie să constrângem fiecare dintre aceste componente să fie ori zero ori
unu, adică de o parte a tăieturii sau de cealaltă putem scrie o funcție ca
o pereche de noduri x i și xJ care ne spune dacă muchia corespunzătoare se află în tăietură, deci plus cantitatea x i + xJ
minus x i xJ identifică dacă muchia se află în tăietură dacă această cantitate este egală
cu unu, aceasta implică că muchia se află în tăietură, altfel este zero și muchia nu se află în ea problema de a găsi
numărul maxim de muchii în tăietură poate fi formulată atunci ca maximizarea acestei funcții, mai departe vom
adăuga de fapt un semn minus global acestei funcții, făcând noua problemă echivalentă cu găsirea minimului acestei funcții
WEBVTT
în schimb și deci minimul lui f de x în acest caz va fi atunci când numărul de muchii traversate de tăietură este
maxim alegem să formulăm această problemă ca o problemă de minimizare deoarece aceasta ne permite să o mapăm ulterior pe o problemă de
minimizare a energiei, adică găsirea stării de bază, ceea ce calculatoarele cuantice sunt în mod natural foarte bune la
dar amintește-ți că nu există nimic legat de Quantum Computing încă, trebuie să reformulăm această problemă în
ceva ce un calculator cuantic poate înțelege suntem acum gata să ne apucăm serios de treabă și
primul pas este să mapăm problema pe un circuit Quantum s-ar putea să nu fie evident cum
vom trece de la un graf ca cel pe care tocmai l-am desenat la un circuit Quantum dar hai să mergem încet amintește-ți că vom
încerca să rezolvăm această problemă Max cut folosind qaoa în algoritmul qaoa dorim în ultimă instanță să avem un operator,
hamiltonianul, care va fi folosit pentru a reprezenta funcția de cost a problemei noastre, precum și un
circuit parametrizat, ansatz-ul sau starea de probă, pe care o vom folosi pentru a reprezenta stări cuantice care sunt estimări educate sau candidați
pentru soluția problemei putem eșantiona din aceste stări candidate și apoi le putem evalua
folosind funcția de cost în acest caz funcția de cost este f de x, dar trebuie să o exprimăm într-un
mod care să se simtă nativ pentru calculatorul cuantic pentru aceasta, vom profita de o serie de transformări
matematice pentru a exprima f de x ca o funcție de energie, hamiltonianul primul pas al
procesului este să exprimăm problema minimizării lui f de x ca o problemă de optimizare binară neconstransă cuadratică
sau QUBO pe scurt QUBO este o modalitate generală de a formula aceste probleme de optimizare combinatorică
aici Q este o matrice N x N de numere reale, N corespunde numărului de
noduri din graful nostru, cinci pentru acest exemplu, și X este același vector de variabile binare din formularea
inițială pentru a rula efectiv algoritmul qaoa, trebuie să exprimăm problema noastră de optimizare în termenii unui
hamiltonian, care este un operator matematic ce reprezintă energia totală a unui sistem, mai specific dorim
să creăm un hamiltonian al funcției de cost care are proprietatea că starea sa de bază sau valoarea proprie minimă
corespunde minimului funcției care codifică numărul maxim de tăieturi pe graful g odată ce
avem acest hamiltonian, tot ce trebuie să facem pentru a rezolva problema de optimizare este să pregătim starea de bază a hamiltonianului pe calculatorul cuantic, apoi
eșantionând din această stare vom obține cu probabilitate mare soluția la minimizarea lui f de X după cum se
dovedește, avem noroc deoarece problema QUBO este strâns legată de și de fapt echivalentă din punct de vedere computațional cu
unul dintre cei mai faimoși și ubiqui hamiltonieni din fizică, hamiltonianul Ising, pentru a scrie problema QUBO
ca acest hamiltonian Ising, tot ce trebuie să facem este o simplă schimbare de variabilă pentru a trece de la
variabile booleene 0 și 1 la variabile de spin minus unu și unu acest pas este
simplu este arătat în mai mult detaliu în anexa notebook-ului atașat pentru cei interesați, dar în final minimizarea acestei expresii QUBO
este aceeași cu minimizarea acestei expresii rescrind din nou ușor și
avem hamiltonianul funcției noastre de cost unde minimul expresiei reprezintă starea de bază și Z
devine operatorul Pauli Z, în timp ce B este un coeficient scalar real acum că avem
hamiltonianul nostru, este simplu să îl rescriem în termenii a doi operatori locali ZZ Pauli care se vor converti ușor în
două gate-uri cubice în circuit-ul nostru Quantum te rog să consulți notebook-ul asociat pentru a vedea cum se face aceasta, dar rezultatul
este dat de această linie de aici notează că în exemplul nostru există
șase obiecte sau șiruri Pauli deoarece fiecare reprezintă o muchie în graf lungimea șirului se potrivește cu numărul
de noduri, deci i i i ZZ are cinci noduri și șirul va fi compus din
identități în toate pozițiile, cu excepția indicilor nodurilor implicate într-o muchie, care vor avea termeni Z, în Qiskit
șirurile de biți reprezentând qubit-urile sunt indexate invers, de exemplu o muchie între nodurile 0 și 1 va fi codificată ca
I I I ZZ cu hamiltonianul scris în termenii operatorilor Pauli suntem gata să construim
circuit-ul nostru Quantum acest circuit Quantum ne va ajuta să eșantionăm soluții bune de pe calculatorul cuantic, algoritmul qaoa
este inspirat din teorema adiabatică care afirmă că dacă începem în starea de bază a hamiltonianului dependent de timp
și dacă hamiltonianul evoluează suficient de lent și beneficiind de suficient timp, starea finală va fi starea de bază
a hamiltonianului final qaoa poate fi gândit ca versiunea discretă Trotter a algoritmului cuantic
adiabatic unde fiecare pas Trotter reprezintă un strat pe care îl vom numi P deci
în loc să evoluăm de la o stare la alta, în fiecare strat P vom alterna între hamiltonianul funcției noastre de
cost și ceva numit hamiltonianul mixer despre care vom mai auzi imediat, dar punctul pe care vreau să îl fac
este că qaoa are avantajul de a fi mai rapid decât algoritmul cuantic adiabatic, dar returnează soluții
aproximative în loc de cele optime în limita în care numărul de straturi tinde la infinit, qaoa converge la cazul
adiabatic, dar desigur acesta este foarte costisitor din punct de vedere computațional pentru a crea circuit-ul nostru Quantum
vom aplica operatori alternanți parametrizați de gamma și beta care
vor reprezenta discretizarea evoluției temporale deci, din nou, cele trei părți principale
ale circuit-ului qaoa sunt: unu - starea inițială de probă în gri, care este starea de bază
a mixer-ului din starea adiabatică de evoluție, creată prin aplicarea unui gate Hadamard aplicat fiecărui qubit, doi -
evoluția funcției de cost pe care o avem deja în violet închis și trei - evoluția sub
hamiltonianul mixer pe care nu l-am discutat încă în violet deschis acum hamiltonianul nostru de start se
numește mixer deoarece starea sa de bază este superpoziția tuturor șirurilor de biți posibile de interes, deci
impunând un amestec al tuturor soluțiilor posibile la început, hamiltonianul mixer este suma simplă a operațiilor Pauli X
pe fiecare nod al grafului Qiskit îți permite să folosești un operator mixer personalizat diferit dacă dorești, dar
pentru acest caz vom folosi doar cel standard deci, din nou, poți vedea că cu Qiskit o mare parte din muncă este
eliminată pentru noi, făcând determinarea hamiltonianului mixer și a stării de start triviale, singura muncă pe care a trebuit să o facem a fost
WEBVTT
să găsim funcția de cost fiecare iterație a acestor operatori se numește un strat, aceste straturi pot fi văzute ca
discretizări ale evoluției temporale a sistemului, după cum a fost descris anterior, tiparul alternant vine din
descompunerea Trotter și aproximează funcțiile exponențiale ale matricelor care nu comută în general, cu cât mai multe straturi sau
pași includem, cu atât mai aproape vom fi de evoluția continuă în timp deci în teorie, cu atât rezultatul va fi mai precis
dar pentru acest exemplu vom începe eșantionând cu două straturi amintește-ți că atât hamiltonianul funcției de cost cât și
mixer-ul sunt parametrizați, trebuie să găsim în continuare valori optime pentru gamma și
beta acum, recunosc că a fost multă informație și dacă vezi acest tip de matematică pentru prima dată poate fi dificil, din fericire unul dintre lucrurile grozave
despre Qiskit este că o mare parte din ce tocmai am trecut poate fi făcut automat fără un efort mare din partea utilizatorului este bine să înțelegi ce se
întâmplă în spate, mai ales pe măsură ce scalăm la experimente mai mari, dar nu va trebui să faci toată această muncă
manual de fiecare dată am mapat acum problema noastră pe un circuit Quantum, a fost un pic de muncă
dar nu-ți face griji, devine mai ușor și mai intuitiv cu cât o faci mai mult acum suntem gata să trecem la pasul doi
optimizarea circuit-ului nostru pentru hardware deci deși circuit-ul pe care tocmai l-am creat arată destul de simplu și este
util pentru a construi o înțelegere intuitivă, amintește-ți că cipul cuantic nu înțelege ce este acest bloc abstract
trebuie să îl transformăm într-o serie de gate-uri de unu și doi qubit-uri care sunt native pentru hardware și când
spun nativ, vreau să spun că va fi refactorizat în ceea ce poate fi executat direct pe qubit-uri astfel de circuit-uri se
spune că sunt scrise în arhitectura setului de instrucțiuni a backend-ului, pe care s-ar putea să o vezi abreviată ca circuit-uri ISA
modulul transpiler din Qiskit SDK oferă o serie de pasaje de transpilare care pot
efectua o gamă largă de transformări ale circuit-ului dorim să ne asigurăm că circuit-ul nostru este optimizat pentru
scopul nostru amintește-ți din lecția anterioară că procesul de transpilare implică mai mulți pași: maparea
qubit-urilor din circuit sau variabilele de decizie la qubit-urile fizice de pe dispozitiv, desfășurarea instrucțiunilor din
circuit-ul cuantic la instrucțiunile native hardware pe care backend-ul le înțelege de fapt, rutarea oricăror
qubit-uri din circuit care interacționează direct la qubit-urile fizice care sunt adiacente unele
cu altele și ca întotdeauna, mai multe detalii despre aceasta se găsesc pe site-ul de documentație
acum vine un pas interesant în care vom alege pe ce backend să rulăm circuit-ul nostru trebuie de fapt să facem asta
înainte de pasul de transpilare deoarece transpiler-ul optimizează diferit pentru procesoare diferite acesta este încă un motiv pentru care este
important că Qiskit poate automatiza atât de mult din această etapă nu ai vrea să trebuiască să îți optimizezi circuit-ul manual
ceea ce se poate face, dar uneori este dificil și consumă mult timp, doar pentru a realiza că de fapt vrei să rulezi
circuit-ul pe un procesor diferit cu proprietăți diferite și atunci trebuie să faci toată acea muncă din nou trece
backend-ul ales prin funcția transpiler și nu uita să specifici nivelul de optimizare al tău de
data aceasta am selectat nivelul de optimizare trei, care este cel mai înalt și mai exhaustiv nivel de optimizare
și asta este tot pentru pasul doi circuit-ul meu a fost transpilat automat și l-am desenat aici astfel
încât să poți vedea cum a fost tradus în gate-uri de unu și doi qubit-uri acum este timpul pentru pasul trei
rularea circuit-ului cu Qiskit Primitives până acum am transpilat circuit-ul lăsând parametrii gamma și
beta la o parte, dar nu putem rula de fapt circuit-ul fără a specifica valoarea acestor parametri în fluxul de lucru
qaoa parametrii optimi qaoa sunt găsiți într-o buclă de optimizare iterativă unde rulăm o serie de evaluări ale circuit-ului
și folosim un optimizer clasic pentru a găsi parametrii optimi beta și gamma, totuși trebuie să
începem de undeva, deci am implementat niște estimări inițiale pentru Gamma 1, gamma 2 și beta 1, beta 2 de Pi / 2 și Pi
respectiv vreau de asemenea să notezi că vom folosi un optimizer pentru a găsi soluții mai bune pentru gamma și beta
și deoarece calculez doar două straturi pentru moment, asta e tot ce am nevoie, dar dacă faci un circuit qaoa mai precis
ai include mai multe straturi și ai avea nevoie de gamma și beta optimizate pentru fiecare strat secvențial
acum hai să luăm un minut să facem o pauză și să ne amintim opțiunile noastre pentru Primitives avem estimator-ul și
sampler-ul pe care crezi că îl vom folosi pentru acest tip de job? ei bine, indiferent pe care l-ai ghicit
ai de fapt dreptate vom folosi atât estimator-ul cât și sampler-ul pentru bucla
inițială de optimizare vom avea nevoie de estimator, dar vom folosi sampler-ul mai târziu pentru a citi soluția
finală acum suntem aproape gata să rulăm algoritmul, promit, dar foarte rapid este important să notezi că poți
trimite job-ul în mai multe moduri diferite care se numesc moduri de execuție mai întâi avem modul job: o singură
cerere primitivă a estimator-ului sau sampler-ului făcută fără un manager de context, circuit-urile și intrările sunt împachetate ca blocuri
primitive unificate, pub-uri, și trimise ca sarcină de execuție pe calculatorul
cuantic modul batch este un manager de job-uri multiple pentru rularea eficientă a unui experiment compus dintr-un grup
de job-uri independente, folosește modul batch pentru a trimite mai multe job-uri primitive simultan modul sesiune: o fereastră dedicată
pentru rularea unui flux de lucru cu mai multe job-uri, aceasta permite utilizatorilor premium să experimenteze cu algoritmi variaționali într-un mod mai
previzibil și chiar să ruleze mai multe experimente simultan, profitând de paralelismul din
stivă folosește sesiunile pentru fluxuri de lucru iterative și experimente care necesită acces dedicat pentru un experiment qaoa,
o sesiune ar fi o alegere bună dacă ai acces la ea, deoarece va trebui să încerci mai multe circuit-uri pentru diferite valori ale beta
și gamma bine, acum să revenim la problema noastră de optimizare am definit deja
hamiltonianul funcției de cost HC și fluxul complet de lucru este acesta: algoritmul
qaoa începe prin inițializarea qubit-urilor în starea de superpoziție și apoi aplică ansatz-ul cu P straturi, inițializează
parametrii gamma și beta și apoi rulează circuit-ul folosind primitiva estimator odată ce calculăm
valorile așteptate, vom folosi apoi un optimizer SciPy numit COBYLA COBYLA
optimizează funcția de cost clasic în afara QPU odată ce acele valori de gamma și beta au fost actualizate
repetăm vom face asta până când valoarea funcției de cost globale a convergit și a atins cea mai mică valoare
WEBVTT
apoi vom selecta valorile de gamma și beta care corespund acestei valori de cost scăzut și vom rula circuit-ul o ultimă
dată acum folosind sampler-ul acesta este rezultatul rulării optimizer-ului COBYLA cu estimările mele inițiale, aici poți vedea
că valoarea funcției de cost de-a lungul iterațiilor efectuate începe puțin haotic și urcă și coboară, dar
apoi se stabilizează la o valoare scăzută vom folosi aceste ultime valori de gamma și beta care corespund costului minim
pentru a rula circuit-ul o ultimă dată și a eșantiona șirul de biți care ne va da max
cut-ul acum folosind valorile noastre optimizate pentru gamas și betas, vom rula circuit-ul o ultimă dată pentru a găsi cel mai bun
șir de biți posibil folosind sampler-ul am listat valorile specifice pe care le folosesc aici, dar amintește-ți că atunci când
încerci tu sau chiar rerulezi același notebook tutorial, aceste valori s-ar putea schimba ușor acum vom rula
circuit-ul nostru optimizat cu aceste valori și vom găsi soluția candidat la problema noastră Max cut dacă ai folosit
sesiuni, acestea nu mai sunt necesare deoarece rulăm doar un ultim job acum vom privi în sfârșit
etapa de postprocesare și găsirea soluției finale mai întâi hai să reprezentăm grafic toate
combinațiile posibile de noduri pe care le-am convertit în șiruri de biți ca o histogramă poți vedea imediat că
atunci când l-am rulat, am găsit patru soluții și le-am evidențiat în violet pe cele care sunt mai probabile decât orice altă soluție
cel mai probabil șir de biți soluție este 0 1 01 te rog să notezi că ordinea qubit-urilor
este inversată în grafic uitându-ne la cea mai probabilă soluție, notăm că nodurile 0 și trei sunt grupate împreună
și similar pentru nodurile 1, 2 și patru putem în sfârșit reprezenta grafic cel mai probabil
șir de biți ca un graf și amintește-ți că șirul de biți corespunde pur și simplu numerelor de noduri și dacă sunt incluse
marcate cu unu sau nu incluse marcate cu zero în gruparea noastră când desenăm tăietura acum putem vedea cu ochii noștri
linia aproximativă pentru cea mai bună tăietură, care reprezintă gruparea ideală a tuturor celor cinci noduri pe care am desenat-o aici
un lucru pe care vreau să îl discut un pic aici este totuși faptul că soluția corectă nu este unică
din cauza simetriei acestui graf există mai multe soluții corecte în loc să ai nodurile 0 și trei
în interiorul tăieturii, am putea avea nodurile 2 și patru incluse și poți vedea că tot ce a trebuit să fac a fost să rotesc tăietura pentru a
include aceste noi puncte această soluție de cinci rămâne aceeași
hai să aruncăm din nou o privire la histogramă și la cele patru soluții cele mai probabile pentru un moment ultimele două soluții sunt
cele pe care tocmai le-am reprezentat grafic și sunt la fel de corecte, dar asta nu e tot am putea de asemenea să inversăm colorarea pentru toate
soluțiile corecte și de data aceasta gândim nodurile ca fiind în interiorul față de exteriorul tăieturii pe
slide-ul anterior am identificat două soluții corecte unice, dar există de fapt încă două soluții, una corespunzând
opusului fiecăreia dintre acestea, uită-te cum în imaginea în care am desenat cele două soluții rămase tot ce am făcut a fost să inversez
culorile acum singura problemă este că algoritmul de fapt nu a găsit sau identificat această a patra ultimă soluție ca
fiind una dintre cele mai probabile patru răspunsuri, a fost a cincea a patra soluție pe care algoritmul a identificat-o
este de fapt incorectă și dacă ai desena-o ai vedea că acea soluție are doar patru tăieturi și deoarece celelalte
au cinci și patru este clar mai mic decât cinci, aceasta este evident greșit punctul de aici
este că acesta este un algoritm aproximativ, nu este infailibil și nu este corect 100% din timp, trebuie să
folosești o parte din propriile cunoștințe și înțelegere pentru a verifica sensul soluțiilor merită să evidențiem că
această eroare poate apărea din mai multe locuri, ar putea fi natura aproximativă a algoritmului în sine și numărul mic
de straturi pe care am ales să le folosesc ar putea fi o eroare de eșantionare finită și aceasta ar putea fi redusă dacă cresc
numărul de shot-uri în experimentul meu sau ar putea fi o eroare de citire deoarece a patra soluție reală diferă cu doar un
bit motivul pentru care subliniez toate aceste posibilități este că asta este ceea ce necesită să devii cu adevărat un
practician al Quantum Computing trebuie să înțelegi performanța hardware-ului și cum poate aceasta contribui
la anumite tipuri de erori și cum să le corectezi cu toate acestea, să nu uităm că
au existat 32 de soluții posibile ca șiruri de biți și că cele patru soluții reale au fost incluse în primele cinci
cele mai bune candidați și am folosit doar două straturi pentru a găsi asta în general, dacă vreau să îmi cresc șansele de a găsi cel mai bun
Max cut de fiecare dată aș crește adâncimea straturilor există câteva subtilități în legătură cu asta, dar asta e pentru un episod ulterior
acum o să te las să încerci tu însuți, dar de data aceasta vei folosi 100 de
qubit-uri deci dacă începem prin a desena graful nostru de 100 qubit-uri, poți vedea că nu mai este simplu sau chiar posibil
să vezi cu ochii liberi unde ar apărea max cut-ul există pur și simplu prea multe posibilități pentru a le putea alege manual, dar
rezolvarea acestei probleme folosind qaoa este în continuare complet fezabilă și poți urma exact același flux de lucru pe care l-am folosit pentru 5
qubit-uri sunt pe cale să te trimit pe cont propriu și să te provoc să faci acest experiment, dar înainte de asta hai
să rezumăm amintește-ți că cei șase pași ai oricărui job qaoa sunt urmă torii: unu - definirea
unui hamiltonian de cost astfel încât starea sa de bază să codifice soluția la problema de optimizare, doi - definirea unui
hamiltonian mixer trei - construirea operatorilor corespunzători hamiltonienilor
exponențiați patru - construirea circuit-ului: va consta din starea inițială de bază a mixer-ului și straturi
alternante repetate ale funcției de cost și evoluția sub hamiltonienilor mixer cinci - pregătirea unei stări inițiale și
folosirea tehnicilor de calcul clasic pentru a optimiza parametrii șase - rularea circuit-ului, măsurarea șirurilor de biți de ieșire
căutând soluția cea mai probabilă acum câteva lucruri de notat: am
folosit nivelul de optimizare trei pentru exemplul meu de 5 qubit-uri, dar poate nu era necesar și răspunsul corect putea
fi returnat de cele mai multe ori la un nivel mai scăzut de optimizare, deoarece adâncimea circuit-ului era destul de mică pentru cazul de 5
qubit-uri, dar pentru cele 100 de qubit-uri și o adâncime mare a circuit-ului, aproape sigur vei avea nevoie de cel mai înalt nivel de
optimizare pentru a găsi răspunsul corect, de asemenea ține cont că unul dintre cele mai dificile aspecte ale unui flux de lucru tipic la scară de utilitate
este etapa de mapare și găsirea unui graf care corespunde bine topologiei heavy hex a IBM dacă faci
această muncă de la zero, fără îndoială acolo ai dedica mare parte din timp deocamdată această parte a fost
WEBVTT
făcută pentru tine deoarece acesta nu este punctul principal al acestui exercițiu, dar ține cont că este ceva ce va
necesita practică și rularea unui job la scară mare nu este întotdeauna simplă vom aprofunda aceasta
în episodul 4 circuit-ul tău final va arăta evident mult mai dezordonat decât circuit-ul care a rulat pe 5 qubit-uri
dar pe de altă parte mă simt că uitându-te la acest circuit și văzând câte gate-uri are și știind că
ai capacitatea de a rula de fapt asta pe procesoare Quantum reale este destul de
impresionant și aceasta a fost soluția mea finală poți vedea că algoritmul este cu siguranță capabil să grupeze aceste
noduri în două grupuri, identificând pretins cea mai bună tăietură Max care le împarte, trecând de la cele două seturi
la linia max cut în sine este trivial oriunde culoarea se schimbă de-a lungul liniilor care conectează nodurile desemnează
unde ar trebui trasată linia max cut când l-am rulat, valoarea max cut pe care am reușit să o ating este
84 deci încearcă tu și spune-mi dacă obții ceva similar în comentarii încearcă trei straturi, poate patru, încearcă
să schimbi ponderile dintre noduri și vezi cum se schimbă rezultatul există o mulțime de experimente interesante
pe care le putem rula cu qaoa acum amintește-ți că nu este garantat că tocmai am găsit cea mai bună soluție posibilă
știm că este o soluție bună, dar ca distracție te provoc să mă întreci, încearcă să obții ceva
mai bun decât 84 în concluzie, qaoa este un algoritm foarte dinamic
și există o mulțime de euristici și multe lucruri de explorat în continuare oferă mult spațiu pentru a învăța lucruri noi
despre domeniul optimizării în general a existat mult lucru recent în spațiul optimizării după
cum demonstrează toate articolele de arhivă care au fost recent publicate online despre qaoa sau optimizare și ceea ce este
cu adevărat interesant este că, în sfârșit, nu toate aceste articole sunt articole teoretice, teoreticienii au lucrat și au studiat
qaoa de ani de zile, dar acum experimentaliștii se implică deoarece avem în sfârșit hardware-ul
precum procesoarele IBM care sunt capabile să ruleze multe dintre aceste experimente trecem din spațiul imaginar
în lumea reală și asta este foarte interesant da, mai există mult de lucru și mai sunt
destule erori pe care trebuie să le rezolvăm, dar progresăm rapid și tu care vizionezi acest
video, dacă ai ajuns până aici, ești capabil să rulezi aceste experimente tu însuți te rog mergi și încearcă să rulezi propriul tău
experiment de 100 de qubit-uri și spune-ne cum a mers urmează tutorialul și vei fi pe mâini bune și dacă
ai întrebări sau te blochezi nu-ți face griji, cu toții ne-am simțit așa sau am avut aceleași întrebări când am început prima dată
să învățăm asta fă tot ce poți, spune-ne cu ce întrebări te confrunți și ne vedem data viitoare
[Muzică]